It is time for Drew's News,
your daily bowl of fresh good news pasta
with that perfect al dente chew.
(Drew slurps)
(Ross giggles)
And with me at the desk
is my main news noodle, Ross Matthews.
That's right, hi, everybody, hi.
(audience cheers)
Oh, I know you're excited about this week.
I know, it's pasta week.
And we're throwing a five day all out pasta party
to celebrate one of the best
foods on earth!
I know.
Oh my God, my favorite.
And to kick it off,
I hear we have a pasta proclamation
from the pasta queen herself,
chef Nadia Caterina Munno.
(audience cheers)
Hi Drew and you Ross, it's me,
matriarch of the macaroni family.
I am so thrilled you're celebrating my favorite food, pasta.
I want you to enjoy all the pastas in the pasta kingdom.
So today I'm officially anointing you
pasta queen and pasta king of pasta week.
You may now put on your crowns.
(audience claps)
Yeah.
First of all,
thank you, Nadia.
Now the pasta queen
is a very, very beloved woman on TikTok
and she was kind enough to do our show
in the very beginning.
We made pasta al limone,
which is one of my very favorite
pasta's in the world, Rossi.
I see that you have a, I'm not kidding.
It's hard to talk 'cause my tongue and my mouth
just wanna be here.
Uh-huh.
You have a different pasta in front of you.
What, pray tell are you eating?
I love, she asked me a question
it's only so she can eat her pasta.
You guys saw that, right?
Like she really doesn't care.
I do care.
I know you care, but you're just focused on that.
So yours is a pasta al la limone, right?
(Drew grunts)
So my favorite pasta is an untraditional one.
It's gonna surprise some of you.
This is cold pasta salad
with the vegetables in it and the mayo base.
You know what I'm talking about?
I love pasta salad, Rossi.
When it's sort of sweet 'cause of the relish.
A little tang.
Tang, girl, this is tangful.
That's exactly what this is.
Well, first up, in our news today and stories
is some noodle news for pasta week.
It's about Robert Pattinson.
Oh, you love Robert Pattinson.
Who doesn't, by the way?
Hello, I don't know.
Is there someone here who doesn't like Robert Pattinson?
Speak now.
Show yourself.
(audience laughs)
Well, either I scared you
or it is true, he is beloved by all.
And The Cut reports
that the newest Batman
has his very own pasta dream.
He wants to create the first pasta
you can hold in your hand
and he calls it pasta cuscino.
He already has run experiments.
He sticks together a lump of penne
with layers of sugar and cheese
and coats it with corn flakes
and then microwaves it.
What, what?
And he says it should be served on a bun, like a hamburger.
It hasn't come together yet, but Robert is serious.
He even met with frozen food companies
against the advice of his management.
Oh dear, oh dear.
I mean that's against nature, don't you think?
All that together.
He coats it with the cheese and then he microwaves it.
And one of the things that I found out
from digging into the details
was that he says all of life's pleasure foods
burgers, sandwiches, tacos, are all hand-friendly
but pasta is not.
And it's time for it to be.
Okay, well...
(audience cheers)
(Drew laughs)
Let me tell you,
how cruel nature is that Robert Pattinson
can look like Robert Pattinson and eat that.
And I would walk by smell it and look like this.
You know what I'm saying?
Unacceptable mother nature.
Also, do you know what cuscino cuscino means?
Cushion.
Cushion, which is exactly what you get
if you eat what Robert Pattinson makes you.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
But you can make me one Robert Pattinson, I'll try it.
Anything that R Patts does works for me.
Works for me too.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪